i know it might be hard to believe but
tyler and cameron winklevoss who the
world got to know
as the villains of the social network
who mark zuckerberg famously
duped and turned their idea into one of
the biggest companies in the world
might actually be at the forefront of a
counterculture movement
i think from the outside the world kind
of wants to not like these guys they're
six foot five blonde
harvard grads they grew up in
connecticut their father was wealthy
they seemed to have everything going for
them and yet after being shunned
by the mainstream venture capital
community and being
cut out of venture capital deals that
facebook had quite
frankly overwhelmed they went a
different direction and
found traction amongst the
cryptographers and the counter culture
world
who are building the foundation of a new
financial and global way of doing
business
in the dozen years since tyler and
cameron battled with mark zuckerberg
they've accumulated a fortune of three
billion dollars
each
[Music]
everybody was skeptical about the
bitcoin and cryptocurrency world for
years they were even more skeptical
about tyler and cameron winklevoss
we were not financial experts when we
came to bitcoin
early on we bought a lot of crypto on
mount gox which famously
imploded and very few people were
believers who actually
imagined where this could go so we
thought for this to go mainstream for
this technology revolution to really
happen
we have to build reliable safe trusted
infrastructure in 2014 they founded the
gemini cryptocurrency exchange
unlike their nemesis whose mantra would
move fast and break things
tyler and cameron winklevoss embraced an
ask permission not forgiveness mentality
gemini is one of the most regulated
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
and while adoption for them has been
slower than for some of the other
bigger exchanges they might be prepared
for what some believe
is the incoming onslaught of
institutional adopters
it started with building a bridge into
the future of money and then
more recently a bridge into the future
of art
we think art should be digital nfts
solve the digital scarcity problem
in 2019 they acquired nifty gateway
in exchange for nfts or non-fungible
tokens that are now taking the world by
storm
i have to talk about the twins don't i
the other twins
nifty gateway was also founded by two
twins
duncan and griffin cockfoster and in
fact these weren't just any two twins
they were two competitive rowers what
had started off as just a way to use
your credit card
to buy nfts was about ready to become an
entire marketplace for nfts
and a place to securely store them quite
frankly as we move
more and more closer to the metaverse
you'll want
art in your online world i need to ask
you since you use it if you can just
please define it what is the metaverse
the metaverse is the recreation of the
offline world in the online
setting i think a good example of the
metaverse would be fortnite
where people have signed in and they
even have held concerts
in the early days it was totally unclear
whether you know people were actually
going to move on to this
this platform and we saw that with
social networking there's so much
skepticism around will people actually
share their stuff
online and and do this and of course we
know how that
that's gone um today data of a social
network is owned by
that company and in the future we
believe it will be owned by the
individual
who provides that data whether it's
photos or content or whatever they will
own
that content and it's theirs and quite
frankly is theirs rightfully we believe
that
if you take a close look at the
companies not only that they're building
but the companies they're investing in
you can start to read between the lines
that a narrative is developing
that what they are building could
someday just intermediate
facebook amazon google and many other
centralized companies
the world that tyler and cameron
accidentally ended up finding themselves
in
might actually make them the perfect
nemesis for facebook
in a way that not even they ever
imagined
[Music]
you